The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get started.
How about the spring weather?
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Tomorrow.
AUDIENCE: Someone needs
to tell New England
that it's the end of April
and it's got to warm up.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It's getting boring now.
We need the spring
weather to come quickly.
Right.
Good.
Great.
So let's see.
So today we have the pleasure
to have Professor Noelle
Selin to lead the lecture.
And Professor Selin is
not only a professor
of [INAUDIBLE] systems
division, but also
the Department of Earth,
Atmospheric and Planetary
Sciences.
So Noelle previous was on
modeling of air pollution.
And has been doing
lots of work on how
to develop an understanding of
policy related to air quality
and pollution,
specifically of mercury.
And through work,
she has observed
firsthand international
negotiations of policy--
basically how this
[INAUDIBLE] is done, I guess.
A policy meeting,
where you really
see all the parties
getting together.
And they the role off
science and ultimately
how these effects how to
look at a global scale.
And as we have been talking
throughout the course,
one of the aspects that is new
from a business perspective
as you get into
environmental topics
is you have to interface
more with stakeholders
or in other traditional ways.
So last lecture we had a
chance to hear from EDF, NGOs.
EDF is of the nice kind of NGO.
From a business perspective,
they want to engage,
but [INAUDIBLE] attack.
On opposing front, as a company
you also need to understand
what kind of shape could
policy take in the future,
and what is the
role of business?
How could this impact business?
Especially how it impacts
supply chains are global.
So with that, Noelle,
the floor is yours.
And thank you for coming.
NOELLE SELIN: Great.
So I want to right off
that I don't know much
about supply chains.
So I'm hoping that this can
be very much a discussion.
I'm hoping to
learn from you guys
as well as talking to you
a little bit about mercury.
AUDIENCE: Switch
your microphone.
NOELLE SELIN: How do I do that?
Can you hear me now?
All right.
So why is the case of mercury
interesting in the context
of sort of international
business supply
chain regulation?
Well, mercury is the
latest, the most recent
global environmental treaty.
So the Minamata
Convention, which
is an international
convention on Mercury,
was signed just this
past October, 2013.
And it is widely
thought of as it's
the first real new global
environmental treaty
in over a decade.
The previous one was also on
a chemicals related topic,
the Stockholm Convention.
So it's an example of
international environmental
cooperation of which
we don't have a lot.
We don't have a lot of concrete
stuff coming out of the climate
negotiations right now.
But this is a brand new
agreed global treaty.
And it's widely thought of
as the first entire life
cycle international convention.
So I'm going to talk
about that in that context
and how it emerged, what some
of the science behind it is,
and how it might influence
thinking about chemicals
regulation in a product
context, because products
are a core area--
mercury in products
are a core area of
mercury regulation
under the convention.
I'm going to talk a little
bit about the interface
as well between
domestic regulation
in the US,
international regulation
in the European
Union context, which
sort of is a
sub-global regulation,
and how that interfaces
with the global context.
So that's sort of where
I'm planning to go.
Please feel free to interrupt
me if you have questions
or want to go in
different directions.
So what I'm going to
start with is just
a little bit about the
scientific backgrounds.
And we're on the
same page on why
we're concerned
about mercury, why
we're having a global treaty
on mercury in the first place.
The reason that mercury
is a global problem
is the mercury
that we're emitting
doesn't stay within our borders.
So the main criteria for having
an environmental regulation
internationally-- there's
a general principle
of international law that
you can do whatever you
want within your own borders.
If you're ruining
your own environment,
it's kind of your problem.
But the minute you start ruining
other people's environments,
that's when it's subject
to international concern.
So if you just emitted
mercury deposited right next
to your power plant or
something and contaminated
your local environment,
it wouldn't necessarily
be subject to
international regulation.
But mercury in the atmosphere
is in a pretty volatile form.
And mercury when you're
emitting it's to the atmosphere,
lasts for about half
the year to a year.
So that means it blows around.
And it blows around
pretty much globally.
If you think about
watching the weather map
and about how far weather
goes in different winds,
you get about 7 to 10 days to
go across continents basically.
So in about six months, you
can imagine that something
that lasts in the atmosphere
that long is going
to mix pretty effectively.
Intra-hemispheric mixing time
is about half the year to a year
as well.
So anything emitted in
the northern hemisphere
is going to go to the
southern hemisphere too.
So mercury all over the
world in the atmosphere.
Now the reason it's a
problem is because of what
happens when it rains out.
When it rains out, it
accumulates in ecosystems.
It turns into methyl mercury.
Methyl mercury is even
more toxic than mercury.
It builds up in food chains--
goes into little fish,
big fish eat the little fish.
In the Arctic, there's a
really long food chain.
Polar bears eat the big
seals, people eat seals,
you get high levels of
a neurotoxin of concern.
So methyl mercury
is a neurotoxin.
It has effects on people's IQs--
in particular, pregnant women
who consume things high in
mercury, particularly fish,
during pregnancy,
their offspring
have neurological impacts
even at of background doses.
Lower IQ outputs.
So this comes from a range
of epidemiological studies.
More recently, lest you
think all of you might be off
the hook, cardiovascular
impacts in the general adult
population.
Some mercury is bad
for everyone, not just
pregnant women and kids.
I'll talk a little bit about
gold mining communities.
Mercury's used in artisanal
and small scale gold mining.
And mercury itself,
at really high levels,
can also be very dangerous if
you breathe in too much of it,
but not really acutely
toxic in the concentrations
that we might likely
be exposed to.
So although it's a concern
to break a thermometer
and you shouldn't
go and sniff it,
you're not going
to expect to see
effects at that
kind of a dosage,
and particularly not at
the dosage of ambient air
concentrations.
But once it gets
into methyl mercury,
once it gets into the food
chain, you have a problem.
Now think about sort
of what's happened
over the last several
decades in terms of where
mercury is coming from.
So you have mercury
that's used in products.
Mercury has been
used for millennia.
In cinnabar ore, which is the
really red rock, used as a dye,
mercury was used in hat making.
It was used in mining all the
way back to the Roman times.
So it's a very useful substance.
But one of the really recent
things that's happened
is that mercury is also
a contaminant in coal.
So if you look at what's
happened in the Arctic,
you can look at
the concentration--
this is kind of squished.
This is sort of
normalized to levels
you can look in various
different archives.
So what happens when they
find the unfrozen polar bear,
they can actually look at
what the concentrations are
in the unfrozen
polar bear that died
in the 1200s over here
that was stuck in the ice
and they found him, as opposed
to current day polar bears,
as opposed to the
museum polar bears
that they killed in the 1800s.
And you can track that with
things like falcon feathers
and ringed seal teeth
and various things.
AUDIENCE: What exactly does
the percent concentration mean?
Surely, human teeth
are not pure mercury.
NOELLE SELIN: Right.
So it's normalized to
present day levels at 100%.
So because the
concentration just
to show everything
on the same scale,
because the concentration
in polar bear hair
is obviously different
from feathers,
is different from teeth.
So with 100% present
day concentrations,
this is how much it would
have increased relative to.
So we can do modeling of what
happens in the atmosphere when
you emit mercury and it blows
around all over the place.
This is what the global
cycle looks like.
It comes from some
of my modelling work.
But again, you're
looking in the Arctic
where there aren't
a lot of sources.
You have a lot of increases.
You have health
effects that you can
estimate hundreds of thousands
of new ones every year.
So there's growing scientific
concern about this substance.
So now what you do about it?
You've got mercury
used in a whole range
of different products.
You've got mercury
coming out of coal.
You want to figure out how
it gets into the atmosphere.
So you do something like
an emissions inventory.
And this is what
the UN Environment
Program put together on
anthropogenic emissions
to the air.
Coal being about a quarter.
This is this artisanal and
small scale gold production.
I'll talk a little bit
more in detail about that
and how they get
their mercury later.
The really interesting
part about this
is we didn't realize that
that was such a big chunk.
I've been working on mercury
for over 10 years now.
10 years ago, that wasn't
even in our inventory.
So realizing how much
mercury was actually
admitted to the
global atmosphere
from these gold
mining communities
was actually a big step.
And you've got a bunch of
other different all kinds
of uses of mercury, uses in
the chloralkali industry.
Disposal of waste for
mercury containing products
is a chunk of
emissions to the air.
Also important in emissions
to water, releases to water.
Cremation is always
an interesting one.
You got mercury in your teeth.
Guess where that goes?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Being a
heavy metal, what's
the mechanism by which say
someone mining for gold-- I
assuming it has to be
highly atomized to be
able to go into the
atmosphere and travel a ways.
NOELLE SELIN: So mercury's
a funky heavy metal.
It's the only one that's
liquid at room temperature,
so you've got elemental mercury
that you can-- basically
thermometer kind of
elemental mercury.
And if you put that in a pan
with gold, it'll form amalgam.
And then all you have to
do, you take that amalgam,
you burn, and mercury
will burn off.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NOELLE SELIN: Yeah.
So sometimes that's
done in gold shops.
And I'll have a slide
later about the process
and where the mercury goes.
But that's essentially
the principal.
And that's why it goes to air.
Of course, there's going
to be some rinsing.
And that's why that numbers are
all uncertain, because again,
this is a sector that's
not very regulated
where the mercury ends up.
AUDIENCE: Why was it overlooked?
What changed that made it
show up in the rater again?
NOELLE SELIN: So
it was whether it
goes to air was the
question, and what fraction,
and how much is used.
So there weren't
very good estimates
because this is generally
kind of an illegal sector
in a lot of places, or at least
an unregulated informal one.
So it may actually have
increased over time
because of the price of gold.
There's more money
to be made in mining
gold, so more use of mercury.
And then what fraction you
assume of how much people
actually keep versus
how much they burn off
has changed over time.
And just the
difficulty in-- it's
pretty easy to get
coal statistics.
Actually, I was one
of the first ones
to actually put an estimate
into a global model of artisanal
and small scale gold mining.
And what I did is I just
took the total amount that
was used, which we had
estimates of, and I said,
these are the countries
in which it's used.
We're going to assume
30% goes to the air
and I'm just going
to grid it, because I
didn't know what to do with it.
Now we have a little
better of a handle on it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What is [INAUDIBLE]
major discovery that
will change [INAUDIBLE] that
you have showing on the site?
NOELLE SELIN: Probably.
I think that artisanal and
small scale gold mining
we could learn a lot more about.
And the uncertainties are huge.
So we're doing some
work with the modeling
and also looking at
measurements in the atmosphere
to try to back calculate
what the emissions are.
One of the key
uncertainties in emissions
is-- the key is that when you
emit mercury, it doesn't stay,
because it's a volatile
heavy metal, weirdly enough.
So when it goes into the
soil, something like lead
will stay there.
But mercury pops back up.
And because we've
been emitting mercury
for decades,
centuries, millennia,
there's mercury enhanced in
the surface ocean, enhanced
in the soil, it keeps
popping back up.
We don't have a good handle
on what that source is
and how much of it is
human versus natural.
So this actually I
did the human in red,
and then it's technically
pre-industrial.
But the problem is-- so
there was a recent paper that
came out that said, yes, mercury
circulating in the system
has gone about a factor of
three since pre-industrial
and we can use lake sediment
cores to figure that out.
But again, the
Romans used mercury.
So labeling pre-industrial
equals natural
is kind of problematic,
because although we've
had a real big spike
from coal, there's
probably human mercury
that's been circulating
that we don't have a good idea.
So they're saying maybe
it's a factor of seven
now as opposed to
a factor of three.
But regardless, current
emissions play a role,
and if you look at
deposition to the US,
this is mercury
actually coming down
in rainfall entering
the US environment.
What you see is you see
a bunch of patterns.
So the highest wet deposition in
the US is actually in Florida.
And that comes from
global sources.
But you can see
that there's also
deposition in the northeast
that comes directly
from the coal power plants.
So not going to go through
all the chemistry of this
because it has to
do with chemical
reactions in the atmosphere.
But the upshot is that if
you want to reduce deposition
over the US in all
these different places,
you have to tackle both the
local sources-- because some
of it actually deposits right
near the source, and some of it
circulates globally-- and the
global atmosphere deposits.
And then actually affects you.
So this is really one of the
motivating things for the US
to get involved both
in mercury policy
nationally and mercury
policy globally.
So just giving you a
little bit of the history.
I'll talk a little bit about
what happened in the US
as well.
But this is something that's
come up in the last 15 years
or so.
The first global
scientific assessment
of mercury that gave this idea
that mercury is a long range
problem-- global action
is necessary to address it
was the main conclusion
that came out in 2002.
So you get this
group of scientists
together under the UN
Environment Program Chemicals
Division and they say, mercury's
a problem, global action needed
to address it.
Now, look, what do we do?
And so the global treaty
as I said was last year.
Now that's a long, long state.
That's 11 years difference.
So what happened
during that time.
Well, what happened was
a lot to do with the US.
And this shows sort
of the influence
of domestic regulation in
the international context.
Those of you who remember
2002 in the US, thee US
administration wasn't so
pro-internal environmental
regulation.
Didn't really like
the idea of signing up
the US to something that
might be questionable in terms
of its cost benefit ratio.
And you know, why mercury?
International cooperation
wasn't necessarily a priority.
International environmental
cooperation even less so.
And the idea that we shouldn't
waste time getting everyone
on board, we should
just do what we
want to do with the
willing partners
was an idea that was
sort of widespread
in the administration.
So they applied that
to mercury as well.
So what they have is the
global mercury partnership.
They said, let's get
together various coalitions
that are going to
attack different aspects
of the mercury problem.
So they had a task force on
artisanal and small scale gold
mining.
They had a task force on
coal fire power plants.
And they did some
voluntary activities,
capacity building in
different countries
to try to reduce emissions.
But there was an
ongoing discussion about
whether that's actually
effective at reducing
the mercury problem or not.
It's pretty much
keeping the mercury
levels constant at this point.
And the European
Union in particular
was very in favor of a
global legally binding treaty
and had been since 2002.
So every two years the UN
Environment Program governing
council meets.
The governing council is
the environment ministers
of all the nations.
And they're the ones really that
would set a mandate actually
negotiate a global treaty.
It would be done under the
auspices of the UN Environment
Program.
Every two years they met.
And in 2000, 2003, US said
now let's do a program.
2005, not so much, US.
Now let's strengthen
the program.
2007, still nothing, although
a couple of other countries
are on board by that time.
Latin America's actually really
interested in doing something
particularly because of
the concerns on artisanal
and small scale gold mining.
Canada also has its phases
of liking or not liking
international regulation.
In the organic pollutants
example, the last convention,
Canada was very much in favor
of negotiating something.
Canada mines a lot of metals.
Not necessarily
mercury, but Canada
was a little afraid that this
was going to be a global metals
treaty and didn't want to
really push for it so much.
So Canada wasn't pushing.
Australia, again, up and down,
but likes its metals too.
So you didn't have a lot of
developed countries pushing.
You had some developing country
blocks getting on board.
So you think about
what countries
and what their different
motivations are.
And then we get to 2009.
And suddenly in 2009, you have
the European Union still saying
we need a global treaty.
By then Latin
America's on board.
We need a global treaty.
And now you have the US saying,
hey, let's not such a bad idea.
Guess what?
We had a administration change.
One of the things that is
important to note about the US
is that President Obama has
made mercury a pet issue.
The US-- and I'll talk
about mercury in products
and how it relates
to the treaty--
has a mercury export ban.
That came in the mid-2000s,
when entry enforcement was
passed I'm not 100% sure.
But the sponsor of that
legislation in the US Senate
was Senator Obama.
So he had a interest
in mercury in general.
And also the US had gone
through about eight or nine
years of trying to regulate
mercury from coal fired power
plants under a court order,
under the Clean Air Act,
and had kind of messed
it up under Bush.
And when Obama came in,
the clean air mercury rule
had been thrown out
of court and they
had to go back and do it again.
And so Obama, being
interested in mercury,
said let's regulate again.
And the Mercury and
Air Toxic Standards
came in 2012 in the US.
But that was well under way.
So the US starts saying, hey,
this isn't that bad an idea.
Because if we want to solve our
mercury problem domestically,
we need both international
and domestic action.
This is kind of a win.
It's also a political win
because protecting babies
and not having
mercury in our food
is a kind of clear
public message as well.
China-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Can you
speak a little bit more
about the cost benefit analysis
and what type of decisions
a politician and
some of these people
are making to make them more
attractive for this type
of law?
NOELLE SELIN: I can't.
I'm actually doing a lot of work
on that in my group right now.
So what they did for the
cost benefit analysis
for the Mercury and
Air Toxic Standards,
it was a little bit of an end
run around the idea of cost
benefit analysis.
Because what they
said was, we're
going to regulate mercury.
It's going to have
benefits particularly
on sensitive groups.
So in terms of overall
economic benefits,
it was hard to get
that number up,
in terms of a strict
cost benefit analysis.
Because the people who
are most harmed by mercury
are the people like
subsistence fishers,
who eat a lot of local fish,
particularly for the domestic.
A lot of general public gets
their fish from cans of tuna
from the Atlantic, the Pacific.
That's going to respond to
global emissions and not
local emissions.
So in the US context where
you have to do a cost benefit
analysis, they ended up
showing the cost benefit
of-- the Mercury and Air
Toxic Standards passed
the cost benefit
analysis because
of the particulate
matter benefits.
Atmospheric particulate
matter contributes
to cardiovascular impacts,
respiratory impacts.
You can show a lot of
deaths if you reduce it.
Multiply that by a value
of statistical like you
paid for almost
anything, and that's
what they did for Mercury
and Air Toxic Standards.
Now are group is actually
doing a more thorough benefits
analysis of the Mercury and Air
Toxic Standards out to 2050.
And we get some
reasonably big numbers
because we look at both the
Minamata and the Mercury
and Air Toxic Standards,
the global and the regional.
But that work's in
progress right now.
But as far as what they
needed for the regulation,
that's what they did.
Globally, they didn't really
do a cost benefit analysis.
It was we need to regulate
where we're kind of agreed
that this is a problem.
Let's go with it.
Partly that's because a
lot of other countries
don't have the tradition
of requiring cost benefit
analysis that the US does.
So hopefully that
gets to your question.
Yeah.
So again, China--
China is about half
of global emissions
of mercury right now.
China wasn't
particularly thrilled
about this whole thing.
But China came around.
Again, the US and the
EU and Latin America,
you get three major blocks.
Canada came around, too.
Australia came around.
Africa didn't really
have anything against it.
They probably a net
gain of resources
from this kind of analysis.
So it's China and India really
who are the most worried
about what they have to do.
And in response to
China, it delayed a year
when negotiations
were going to start.
So they didn't start till 2010.
China wanted to
delay them a year
because China was putting
in its own mercury
regulations for its power plants
as part of their next five year
plan.
So China does have
mercury regulations.
They're not
particularly binding.
They're not particularly strict.
But they copied Germany's
and said let's put mercury
in our regulations.
They do you actually have
quite a bit of technology
on their power plants.
Whether it's operating
or not is another thing.
But in terms of build out
capacity, they're there.
So actually negotiating
the instrument
took five negotiating sessions.
It was signed in 2013.
Now once an
international agreement
is signed by
countries, they have
to go and ratify it, make it
consistent with their US law.
That in the US usually has
to go through the Senate.
In this case, it did not.
The US accepted a procedure
equivalent to that
of ratification,
the Mercury Treaty
becoming the first
party because it
was so consistent with US
law that it essentially
was an executive decision.
The administration
said, we don't actually
need to do anything.
It's pretty much an
embodiment of US law.
Because we're doing
so much on mercury,
this does not go much further
than the US already goes.
So that's one
particular lesson is
that the US and the EU
in particular, and you
can see this also in the
reading about the EU,
these national
laws often are sort
of leading the
international standards.
So it's actually
predictable in the sense
that you're not going to get
countries like China, countries
in Africa, to do the same kinds
of end of pipe expensive power
plant controls that you
might expect in the US
when they don't even
have the basic controls
or maybe don't even have
power plants to begin with.
So again, thinking
about what it's
sort of a lowest
common denominator
that you often get in these
international agreements.
So one emphasis of the
agreement was emissions.
And I'm not going to talk too
much about emissions given what
you guys are
interested in-- again,
that's the power sector
part-- but that was only one
component of the tree.
Another is mercury in
products and processes,
which I think is of probably
more interesting to you guys.
So I'm going to talk about
products and processes.
And I'm going to talk about
what they did with artisanal
and small scale gold mining,
because those both have kind
of supply chain type issues.
So where do you see mercury
in products and processes?
So one that is pretty
familiar is thermometers.
So again, phasing out
in places like the US.
You don't see them that often.
But thermometers, blood
pressure measuring devices,
some of the old
thermostats have mercury.
So this whole idea of electrical
control and switching,
measuring and control.
Batteries, older batteries.
Again, phased out in
the US and the EU,
but common elsewhere
sometimes still.
Lighting.
Fluorescent lamps.
Both regular fluorescent
lamps, the tube versions,
and compact fluorescent lamps.
So save energy on balance, but
use a small amount of mercury.
LEDs don't have mercury.
But again, with people
encouraging more and more
compact fluorescent and
fluorescent use in lighting
because of their energy
efficient properties,
mercury becomes an issue, and
safe disposal becomes an issue.
The other is your teeth.
Dental amalgam.
So again, some countries have
phased out the use of mercury
in fillings.
Others don't.
It's pretty cheap.
Even in the US, if you
actually go to the dentist
and you need a
filling and they say,
do you want the silver
one or the white one,
and the white one's a lot
more expensive even here.
So think about if
you're in a developing
country what your option is.
Your option is probably
no dental care at all,
but the silver filling
is probably much better
to have-- you save your
tooth-- than the white filling,
the composite, which is much,
much more expensive for you.
So use of mercury
in dental amalgam
was, are we going to
keep using it or not?
Again, can be an
environmental issue
when people get
cremated and get across.
And then there's a
bunch of other things.
Chloralkali plants-- so use of
mercury in industrial processes
that are phased out in some
cases, but not in others.
Vinyl chloride monomer,
particularly in China,
mercury is used.
So you've got a substance
that you think, mercury,
it's a really concrete
thing to regulate.
But then think about
all these industries
that you've now involved.
So you've got a group
sitting in negotiations.
I actually took a group
of 10 graduate students
to the final negotiating
session, which was in Geneva.
And you've got a group
of maybe 75 people
in the room,
representatives from all
the different countries.
Industry could come
in as observers.
But again, if you're an
industry that does this,
think about how
long and how intense
your observation had to be.
You're going to send a person
to every week long meeting
during five negotiating
sessions through 2010 to 2013,
spending a week in Geneva
each time just to think about,
if you're in the electrical
control and switching industry,
to raise their hand every
time electrical control
and switching comes up.
And they're not really even
allowed to raise their hand,
because the only people
that are technically
allowed to talk on the
floor are countries.
So what you can do as
an electrical control
and switching person
is you can go and lobby
your friendly countries.
You can put out a poster
in the lobby and say, hey,
this is how these
regulations would affect us.
There's probably somebody
next to you that says,
we have the mercury
free version.
Come buy it.
And so depending on your
country and where you are,
this is what it looks like.
In the products group, it became
a little bit more informal.
There were companies that
participated in discussions
as observers.
They talked about
thresholds of where mercury
would be restricted or not.
And the companies
started saying, well,
there's an alternative
for this, but there's not
an alternative for this.
So as you think about
the major categories,
you have ones that are a
lot in developed countries
and then ones that are primarily
in developing countries.
And these are things that used
to be in developed countries
quite a bit but have
often phased out.
So how do you think about
regulating something
internationally?
Now there was two
different approaches
and they refer to them as
positive and negative lists,
which is a little bit confusing
because it meant the opposite
of what you might think.
But the idea is
that you either say,
I'm going to list all these
things that are banned
and you can't use
mercury in them,
or I'm going to ban
mercury in all products
and I'm going to make a list
of the ones you can still
use mercury in.
So the idea of banning
mercury in all products
was kind of a nonstarter
because, again,
things like compact
fluorescent lamps
had benefits that were greater
than the cost of mercury.
Actually no one was really
suggesting that you go back
to incandescence because they've
actually done on the assessment
that if you actually have a very
heavy coal load in your power,
the mercury that you save by
going to a compact fluorescent
is much larger amounts than
the mercury that's actually
in the light bulb.
And there's a move to
get less and less mercury
in that light bulb.
So the idea that
they came up with
was-- there was a
lot of discussion.
Do you have the blanket
ban with the exceptions?
Do you just list the ones that
you're phasing out and banning?
And they came out
the latter approach.
But then they had
to negotiate which
of these things on this list was
on there, which was exempted,
and if there were
thresholds to each of these.
So what kind of level
of mercury would you
accept in these or not?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I'm just
wondering why they
would go about it
that way trying
to create an exhaustive
list when they don't know
future technology
that's going to come out
rather than setting
out a set of criteria
that's saying if thee
product meets a, b, and c,
then you can it?
NOELLE SELIN: Who decides
on those criteria?
Or actually reviews whether
you actually met those?
And part of that
is transparency.
So what countries have to do is
then go back to their countries
and say, what am I allowing?
What am I not?
You have to know what you
can put mercury in and not.
So there's kind of a
transparency approach
that happens.
I think the two
options that came up,
the either blanket ban
plus exceptions or the we
list the things that
they we're banning,
were kind of the two approaches
that they most looked at.
Because again, that would
make it even more wishy-washy,
I think, because then
you could show, oh yeah,
well I fulfilled these
three requirements.
So that wouldn't
be that stringent
in international context because
there's no body that can really
certify those requirements.
So the key with
international regulation
is that there's no
enforcement essentially.
It's an environmental treaty.
You can barely enforce the ones
that actually involve weapons.
You're not going to
go bomb someone that
is using too much mercury.
What's going to happen
is you're going to say,
hey, you're using
too much mercury.
We're going to caution you.
We're going to shame you in
the international context.
We're not going to let you vote.
Maybe we'll actually
give you more money,
because probably the
reason you're not complying
is because you can't afford it.
That's what really happens.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So I've heard from
friends that we
have an island in French
Polynesia called New Caledonia.
The island basically
has a lot of copper.
And so copper is
an industry there.
And to say the only industry.
And basically the
rivers that were blue
once have turned red
because of mercury.
The level of contamination
of the rivers and the island
is-- it was a paradise.
It's extremely high.
And it's still
the only industry.
So it's the main and only sort
of employment in the island.
And there's nobody who
will say anything about it,
or nobody pretends to do
anything about it because I
feel that if it's
not a consensus,
there's still an
understand that it's
the only way the island
can have any income.
And there's nothing to develop.
The [INAUDIBLE]
is not developed.
There's really [INAUDIBLE]
except for this.
So how would you go about it?
Because when I
was there it there
it was really sad to see that
such a beautiful place could
be damage with nobody really
wanting to do anything.
NOELLE SELIN: I think that's
really the larger challenge
that you see in these global
environmental negotiations
because you have a lot
of places like that
with various
different specifics.
But the idea is, how
do you balance benefits
to people-- like
building energy--
versus environmental damages?
And the solution that the
international community
does-- I wish I had a better
solution-- but it's basically
throw money at the problem.
Capacity building,
different techniques,
try to get cleaner
processes, build awareness.
That's pretty much the--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] allowed
to the big countries or--
NOELLE SELIN: A lot of
it's local awareness, too.
So in mercury--
AUDIENCE: Seek a
solution locally?
NOELLE SELIN: Yes.
So in the mercury
negotiations, there
was a lot done-- so a lot of the
nongovernmental organizations
have banded together
internationally
into a more mega group.
So you have some local
nongovernmental organizations
who have kind of partnered
across in mercury action
network or something.
I forget exactly
what it was called.
But that was an umbrella
group of a bunch
of different very local
nongovernmental organizations,
a lot of whom work in these
artisanal and small scale gold
mining communities,
which is actually
very similar to
this kind of issue,
which I'll talk about next.
But yeah, the idea is that
you can do awareness raising
workshops.
So they bring in
international experts,
national experts, talk about
the damages of mercury,
talk about what you could
potentially be doing about it.
That's sort of where
the state of art
is, I think, at this point.
But yeah, so you had to go
through these major categories
of mercury use.
And then I just want to flip
ahead a little bit to actually
what happened.
Again, you have different
phase outs and phase downs.
And then there's this very
legalese exemption period
where you can have
either general exemptions
or specific exemptions.
Another area where mercury
was generalized exemption
was mercury used as a
preservative in vaccines.
So that was one that, again,
this sort of cost benefit
analysis-- there's no
evidence that it's harmful.
Again, other than the
general sense that we
want to phase down mercury.
But it's been phased out
for precautionary reasons
and also because,
again, don't want
to use too much mercury
in developed countries.
But what happens is in
developing countries,
you have vaccines that it means
it doesn't need refrigeration
if you use a mercury
containing preservative.
So again, you're
getting vaccines
to places where you don't have
refrigeration if you use it.
So that's why that ended
up in a general exemption.
AUDIENCE: I do go
through this process.
And when does the science
get into the discussion.
Because you have at some
point to decide [INAUDIBLE].
They know exactly what
levels to be allowed
and they want to
just being reflected.
So I'm wondering where
does this get in.
NOELLE SELIN: It's a lot less
technical than you think is.
So where the scientific
analysis came in
was really in that global
mercury assessment 2002
and the updates of that.
And then the
negotiator said, yeah,
the scientific case is made
that we ought to reduce mercury.
There is no particular substance
by substance sense of when they
actually thought to phase out.
No one did an analysis of what
the benefits of phasing out in
switches and relays versus
linear fluorescent lamps.
That just wasn't even
on the radar screen.
There were assessments that
said where are the sources?
Where does mercury go?
But then it was really a
horse trading kind of thing.
I'll give you
switches and relays
if you give me cosmetics.
Because each country
wants to sort of
protect its own interests there.
Some might have mercury
free alternatives
that they might want to sell.
Others it might be a
particularly pressing issue,
like this cosmetics.
It might be a particular
public health issue
in countries and in regions.
Mercury is a component
of some skin lightening
creams which have been--
people have tried to ban them.
But again, countries with less
of a regulatory infrastructure,
it actually-- again,
putting mercury directly
on your skin, not a good idea,
and can be a big public health
problem in some
communities where there's
an interest in using these
things culturally and also
in cultural practices,
like use of mercury
in religious types of practices
that can be dangerous.
So those cosmetics again,
greater than one PPM.
Also topical antiseptics,
pesticides, biocides,
that kind of thing, use mercury
to toxic kill the bacteria.
There's other ways to do that.
But again, in countries where
you can't really control import
very well in terms
of your capacity,
international
regulation can be an end
run around that to think about.
And again, for dental amalgam
there was a goal of phase down.
But again, no set date.
So to the extent
that you can, use
the more expensive but more
environmentally friendly
alternatives.
And that actually ends up
getting into the environment
quite a bit.
Story in Massachusetts when
they required dental separators
in dental offices-- it used
to be that they just flushed
the stuff down the drain when
they changed your filing--
they required dental
amalgam separators.
You can actually
look at that date
and look at the
mercury level in fish
in the waterways
of Massachusetts
and it goes dramatically
down right after that.
It actually does wash
right into the waterways.
Again, it's a lot of mercury
that's in a particular filling.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
When they pick a date
to phase this out,
2020, is this just sounds
good or is there some--
NOELLE SELIN: It
just sounds good.
AUDIENCE: Let's make
it far, far, far away.
Not next year, not two years.
Something that--
NOELLE SELIN: And
it's negotiated.
So people that want--
again, a lot of these things
are phased out in Europe.
And so the companies have
figured out a way around them.
Europe has an interest in
getting these things globalized
because they have very
strict regulations like we
and like rows that
talk about what
you need to sell
products in Europe.
And to the extent that
becomes a global regulation,
that obviously favors-- Europe
thinks it's the right thing
to do, first of all.
But also it makes
it a global standard
as opposed to different
standards throughout the world.
So you've got European
countries often
pushing for earlier
and earlier phase outs.
Now maybe China for example,
which actually produces
a lot of these compact
fluorescent lamps,
probably wants later
phase in dates.
So 2020 emerges as a compromise.
Again, thinking about the
timing of actually entering
into force for a treaty, I think
you need 50 parties ratifying.
US ratified really, really
quickly, because again,
it just said rubber stamped it.
It's the only country
to ratify so far.
So conservatively at least 2015
before it enters into force.
So setting a day before
that would be kind of weird.
So yeah, you have
to phase it out
before you actually signed it.
So 2020 is a relatively
early date in this area.
Mercury mining is phased
out also under the treaty,
and it's 2035.
Or no-- I think it's
15 years after entry
into force for that particular
country or something like that.
So it can be quite a long time.
So going back a little bit
talking about mercury trade--
so this just gives you a sense
of where mercury is flowing
and where it's going--
again, since we've
had the mercury export ban act.
But this is actually just
of commodity mercury.
So this isn't
mercury in products.
So the compact fluorescent
bulbs that we import from China
are not included in these flows.
Yet primary mercury
mining in Kurdistan,
they're actually closing
their mine partly because
of US assistance.
China has no interest in
actually closing their mine,
although they will have to under
the treaty if they ratify it.
But China's mostly using itself.
So the mercury that
gets used in products--
so you don't see much of an
arrow there coming out of China
because it's not
internationally traded.
But again, a lot of flows
for a lot of this mercury
is coming from recycled mercury,
mercury stocks, mercury in use.
So you've got mercury
flowing as mercury,
then getting incorporated
into products.
You get obviously the trade
in products, and then trade
in wastes.
So once the product is no longer
useful, what do you do with it?
I said that the mercury is a
full life cycle convention.
It does is actually
sort of yield
a lot of the waste issues
to the Basel Convention,
which deals with
wastes internationally.
So it has sound guidelines
of trans-boundary movements
of hazardous waste.
And that pretty much
covers the mercury.
So they tried to
make that consistent.
Problem is that it doesn't
have the same set of parties.
In particular, the US is not
party to the Basel Convention.
But pretty much does
the required things
that the Basel Convention
does in the sense
of being able to deal
with hazardous waste
in a reasonable way.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] if they
cut off the influx of mercury
then they will only be
stuck with trying to manage
their own creation of mercury?
NOELLE SELIN: Right.
And to the extent that
they actually use mercury--
I'm not sure exactly what
the use of mercury will be.
But again, trade is
restricted under the treaty.
US already has an export ban.
EU has an export ban.
Mercury trade will only be
allowed for exempted uses.
So if you're making
one of those exemption
processes like dental amalgam--
that might be Australia.
It might just be
importing for teeth.
Who knows?
But again, if you're using it
for an exempted use, it's OK.
If you're not, it's not.
And that sort of actually
is a really good segue
into the artisanal and
small gold mining story.
Because again, thinking
about where mercury goes
and where mercury is in trade,
artisanal small scale gold
mining is a really big deal in a
lot of countries, big emission.
But the question is, how
do they get their mercury?
You're a small scale gold
miner in a developing country.
You need to buy mercury to
figure out how you actually
mine your gold.
So this is a figure
from a paper that
looks at what the artisanal
and small scale gold mining
process is and how that relates
to the gold supply chain, which
I thought would be
interesting for you guys.
So you started at the top with
mercury exporting countries.
And a lot of those
exporting countries
think they're
exporting to dentists.
So one of my colleagues works in
the artisanal small scale gold
mining area and he
showed this picture
of an artisanal small scale
gold mining community.
And it was mercury dental shop.
Like yeah, right.
You're a mercury dental shop.
You're in a gold
mining community.
But in a lot of cases,
they'll buy mercury
from dentists or
a dental middleman
and actually sell
illegally to the miners.
So then you're the miner,
and miners over here,
they dig your pit.
You get the ore.
And then mix it altogether.
So then what you're
left with is you're
left with some mercury
amalgamated with gold.
And you've got some waste.
And that's where you
have this amalgam ball
and you have the waste.
Now the waste is going
to have some rock in it,
it's going to have
some water, it's
probably going to have
some mercury in it,
because you couldn't get all
of it to stick to the gold.
And what do you do with that?
You just dump that.
So you release mercury
laden byproduct
into the waterways, which
could have local impacts.
But probably not going
to enter the global pool.
Because again, you just rinsed
it out into your local place.
It might.
We don't know the
science on that.
But you've got
amalgam ball, which is
must your money, with your gold.
But it's bound up
with the mercury.
So what do you do?
You can do a couple of things.
You can burn it yourself.
So this would be
the artisanal part.
You're actually going
to just get a pan,
you're going to light
a fire under it,
and you're going to let
the mercury burn off.
Now that's not
particularly efficient,
but it's probably the cheapest
way you're going to do it.
Now one of the ways to
minimize the mercury loss
is to have a retort.
So basically you have
a little cap on it.
The mercury condenses and
then you drip the mercury back
into a little cup.
You could use the mercury again.
It saves it from going
into the atmosphere.
It also saves you
some money because you
don't have to go back
and buy more mercury,
or buy less of it.
So that's been one
of the things that
has come up in trying to
minimize the mercury lost.
But again, as you
think about it,
not the most healthy
place in the world to be,
breathing over a
burning mercury pit.
Again, lots of local issues.
So you've got this AGSM product.
Sometimes that burning can
happen in local shops as well.
That's more of a small scale.
So you take your amalgam
ball to your local shop.
More efficient.
That guy's going to get a cut.
So you think about that
depending on the community.
That might happen.
Usually a buyer, who can
double as a mercury dealer,
buys that intermediate gold
product, does a final burning
step that makes
it more pure gold,
then you enter the
regular gold supply chain.
And you end up with, on
the market, about up to 30%
of artisanal and small
scale gold mining gold
that then goes to a combination
of jewelry and investors
in industry.
So it really is not a
insignificant amount
of gold on the market that
comes out of this process
and involves mercury.
So again, with the
price of gold the way
it is, this is
something that has
a lot of influence on
the livelihood of people
who are involved in this.
So it's a development issue.
It's a local community issue.
It's also an international
market issue.
So there's a lot of
different certifications
that come into gold,
some of which--
at least one, I forget
the-- I don't have it
in my notes, the
particular ones.
But one of which does
incorporate mercury
into the certification
standards and one doesn't.
So there's a difference in--
there's a couple of different,
like fair trade,
fair mine, the talk
about the conditions of the
miners and various things.
Whether or not-- and
how-- they cover mercury
is an open question.
So will that help if you
have more of a certification
process?
Not sure.
Now how does the
treaty deal with this?
Well, it has a
number of provisions
that really boil down to
essentially capacity building,
suggests that to the extent
possible these sectors be
regulated and sort
of formalized,
because they're often
informal sectors.
Again, illegal mercury, black
market mercury essentially,
that's from dentists.
The types of
technologies that can
prevent the releases of mercury
and make it a little safer
be adopted in a more
widespread basis.
But again, it's not eliminating
artisanal small scale
gold mining because that is a
livelihood for a lot of people.
It's trying to make it less
mercury dependent and less
toxic, both for the miners
and for the environment.
So they've basically estimated
that they could probably
have the amount of mercury
based on these estimates.
So there's a lot of opportunity
for reductions, again,
because a lot of these processes
are really inefficient.
So I want to just
end with talking
about sort of the
general context
in which this mercury
regulation is happening,
which is the overall
international regulations
and what's happening globally.
Because obviously these
producers and people
who are dealing with
mercury related issues
aren't just dealing with this as
an international environmental
issue.
There might be other chemicals,
other different kinds
of considerations.
So this is a figure
that one of my students
put together after going
through the negotiations of all
the different international
organizations that had
a roll in the mercury treaty.
And one really obvious link is
through the existing chemical
treaties and institutions.
So the Stockholm
Convention is on
persistent organic pollutants.
So a lot of pesticides-- DTP,
PCB, industrial chemicals
like PCBs, also regulating
dioxins and furans
internationally.
The Rotterdam Convention is on
trade in hazardous chemicals.
It's a prior informed
consent provision,
so it mandates
that countries that
are taking imports of
hazardous chemicals
must give their informed consent
prior to that chemical being
exported.
This is trying to prevent
the idea of something's
banned in the US.
The US decides you
guys will take it,
so let's just export it to you.
The idea is it shifts the
burden to the exporting country
to make sure that that country
knows what it's getting
and knows that you
think it's dangerous.
So there's a list of
chemicals on that convention.
Again, that's similar to
the prior informed consent
process that's in the
Basel Convention that
deals with wastes.
So again, there's
potential synergies there
because Rotterdam
and Basel also have
things potentially
containing mercury
and also this issue of trade.
Funding often comes from the
Global Environment Facility,
which is basically donations
from the rich countries.
Minamata Convention
has an additional new
designed specific
funding mechanism
to be negotiated fully.
But that has to do with issues
that developing countries
in particular have with the
Global Environment Facility
and its responsiveness.
So that was negotiated as
kind of a hybrid compromise.
Possibly some
multilateral funds that
actually influence other
environmental negotiations.
But you have a bunch of other
international organizations
like World Health Organization
that sets guidance
for mercury levels
in fish and also
is involved in
the vaccine thing,
related to the dental thing.
So thinking about connections
with that because you
get very health relevant issue.
International Labour
Organization--
obviously in
particular the miners,
and what people are exposed
to in particular factories is
often in ILO.
Food and Agriculture
Organization, to the center
that involves pesticides.
That's one that comes up.
So that's the
international bits.
You've also got a bunch
of guiding principles that
come out.
The idea that you
can do whatever
you want to your own
environment but you
have to watch out
with others comes out
of the Rio Declaration.
That's 1992.
There's the general discussions
over a sustainable development.
These all kind of
inform in a general way
the kinds of regulations
that are developed
under the Minamata Convention.
Things like the
precautionary principle
come out of these principles.
And then, of course, you have
multilateral regulations--
domestic agreements,
bilateral agreements,
regional agreement--
that are also
dealing with mercury
but on different levels
and among different
countries that may or may not
be consistent or not.
Again, domestic
governments try to make
it as consistent as possible
in the negotiations.
But everyone's
trying to do that,
so it might not be possible.
So that's all I had
for prepared slides.
I was told to keep it to about
an hour-- I think I made it--
and open up for
discussion after that.
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering what
happens to mercury
once whoever's doing
the proper disposal gets it.
Do they convert it to
some safe chemical?
Do they put it barrels and bury
it under a mountain in Nevada?
NOELLE SELIN: The latter.
Mercury's an element.
You can't get rid of it.
So not much you can do about it.
The nice thing is, the
quantities are pretty small.
So again, encapsulating
it, burying it barrels
is pretty much what
you want to do with it.
Again, you're talking
about tons per year.
When you're talking about
carbon it's gigatons per year.
Mercury is in actual
tons per year.
And mercury is pretty dense.
So this is also why your
clump of mercury in your tooth
or in the thermometer is
actually pretty significant,
because there's a lot of
mercury there in comparison
to the global budget,
whereas the amount of carbon
is teeny tiny.
But yeah, I'm not sure
about Nevada specifically.
You could put it in a trailer.
I've seen mercury trailers.
The strategic mercury stockpile
was in trailers for a while.
AUDIENCE: Sounds pretty secure.
So do you see a company
that you thought
was doing something right,
in terms of understanding
the role that they could play?
Because this seems
pretty out of my hands.
So as a company at
the end of the day,
there's nothing I can do.
I just probably can go
to local state official,
voice my concerns,
hopefully get him elected,
and let the whole
thing just kind of--
NOELLE SELIN: There were
definitely companies
involved, but in a limited way.
The lighting manufacturers
were there a lot.
But mainly I saw them
talk about their products
and their minimization and
really kind of get the message
that we are trying to take the
mercury out of our lighting
and we're doing a good
job, so don't ban us.
And I think to that
extent there was
a lot of awareness
raising of technologies
and available technologies
that was done by companies
in these international fora.
Again, it's an
opportunity to trumpet
your green technologies.
So that would be sort of the
positive end of companies
advocating-- mercury free
alternative companies,
definitely.
If you had a
mercury-free something,
you definitely were
waving the flag for it.
There were other
companies that were there
to make sure that their
interests were protected.
Oil and gas.
Mercury is a small
contaminant in oil and gas.
Mercury is mostly
a concern on site.
So because of the way oil is
distilled in the final product,
there's not of mercury.
If you have the
unfortunate location
of being near a mercury deposit
when you're drilling your oil,
you've got a problem.
But you've got a
problem there, and you
have to deal with it there.
Because if you get mercury into
your oil distillation process,
it really gums up the works
as far as I understand.
So the companies
were saying, hey,
this is not really an
international problem.
This is something we deal with.
We would really
prefer that you not
regulate mercury and oil and
gas in an international way.
And there were a lot of
countries on that bandwagon,
too.
Once it was clear that mercury
emissions regulations were not
going to be applied
to oil and gas,
Saudi Arabia decided that they
were going to go to lunch.
So things like that.
And again, awareness raising
of the kinds of things
that international
industries do.
So even if it's not
subject to the regulation,
you have assessments
that come up
that say, what are
best practices?
Because your multinational
companies might know
this is what you do when you
hit mercury in your gas deposit,
but not all companies
might be aware of that.
So again, that comes into the
capacity building, awareness
raising, making
toolboxes to figure out
how much mercury you're
emitting in your process.
These things come out of
international negotiations
a lot.
AUDIENCE: The other
observation-- we
we're going through
the importance of US
and European relation to set
the way-- so in some sense,
if you do what Europe
is doing, you're
in pretty good shape in
terms of anticipating
what could become global.
Is that a fair assessment?
NOELLE SELIN: I
think that's fair,
and I think that's
a strategic choice.
So one of the things that
that's changed over the years--
it used to be that
the US was really
the global standard leader in
international environmental
things.
And the US was kind
of a first mover
in a lot of things
like the Clean Air Act,
pesticide regulation, et cetera.
And in the last decade,
decade and a half or so,
it's really been the EU.
The EU is really the
global standard leader
in the international
environment,
particularly in
the chemicals area.
And I think there's a
clear effort by the EU
to actually globalize
these kinds of standards.
A strategic goal, in a sense.
And part of that's
competitiveness, part of that
is, well, we think it's
the right thing to do.
Because it makes
everybody safer,
and if we think something's too
dangerous for our population,
why should it be OK for others?
But again, with these kinds of
chemicals regulations that are
going in the EU, you see that.
Now, you do see
push back on that.
The US saying, hey,
this is too far.
And it ending up in trade
disputes and various things.
You see that with CO2.
But I think you do see
chemicals versions of that.
But again, it's a
multi-level thing, too.
In the US
traditionally how a lot
of these environmental
regulations came to pass
was that you have
a leading state.
So the US regulation for the
Toxics Release Inventory,
where you have to report
if you release toxics,
came out of really a state
initiative in New Jersey first.
So you get a few leader states.
California does a lot
in terms of leading
environmental regulation.
The interaction between
California and the EU
is actually really
interesting because you
see California now copying
a lot of the EU regulations.
You do see a lot
of copying as well.
A lot of developing
countries when
stressed with the idea of doing
environmental regulations says,
gee, what's Germany doing?
What's the US doing?
Can we just go with that?
Because again,
the capacity to do
these kinds of real
technical analyses of, well,
do we set it at five?
Do we set it at seven?
What does really make sense?
A lot of developing
countries don't have that,
so they say-- that's
really how China
developed their
mercury threshold is
took the one from Germany.
I talked to the
Chinese researchers
that have informed that.
And there's a lot of
research on Mercury in China.
But we've interviewed
them and they said, yeah,
basically took Germany's.
Seemed reasonable.
And also that's
going to be where
we're going to buy our emission
control equipment until we can
figure out how to make it, so
if they're going to make it
for German market,
we're not going
to set a more
stringent one and then
we're not going to be
able to buy the equipment
and meet it until
we can make it.
It just makes sense
with a globalized market
for those things.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that the Basel
did the same for [INAUDIBLE],
copy just like that.
They just didn't-- no local
analysis, no country--
same thing.
NOELLE SELIN: Yeah.
But that's something
that you really start
to see in these negotiations.
So it's even more
prevalent in climate.
But even in mercury
you see this,
that a lot of
developing countries
have one person at
this negotiation.
US delegation was
about 20 people.
so US would have
someone from the EPA,
and someone from the
State Department,
US Trade Rep's office,
and they had some
health experts,
they had people
that did vaccines.
So they had a broad range
of expertise-- the emission
control, the
products people, they
were all in different groups.
And even in mercury, which
is a fairly small area,
you could assemble that team.
Now, you've got people
from African countries
and you've got one person.
You've got two or three
groups going at the same time.
You have to deal with
emissions from power plants.
You have to deal with products.
And the way it
works in the US is--
I know the people who work
on mercury-- mercury's
almost their whole job, because
they're dealing with mercury
in Air Toxic Standards, they're
dealing with scientists,
there are scientific
assessments going on.
The person in a developing
country in mercury,
they're probably running the
whole environment division.
They might be
running environment
and labor and health.
Especially smaller
island states,
you've got a couple of
hundred thousand people
in your population.
How much can you
environment ministry?
So a lot of these
regional consultations
become very important.
But capacity really,
really comes into play.
When we were at negotiations,
this negotiation to exhaustion
comes in, too.
Because like you
would expect, no one
wants to compromise till
the very last minute.
So when we were there at the
final negotiating session,
the deadline was-- the
meeting was scheduled
through Friday, 6:00 PM.
We got to agreement
Saturday morning at 8:00 AM
after negotiating all night.
So if you have a couple
people on your delegation,
you can take naps.
If you don't, you're
kind of challenged.
AUDIENCE: Take naps.
NOELLE SELIN: Yeah.
And you miss something.
Yeah.
Exactly.
So again, you have to rely
on other friendly countries
in the region.
And a lot of that is done
to try to facilitate--
in a sense, a lot of
the African countries
have a lot in common in the
negotiation and sort of bond
together.
But again, countries that have
a very particular interest
might not get that represented.
And then they have to
go back and figure out
what it means for
their own legislation
in the context of all the other
things that they're doing.
AUDIENCE: So will
you please talk again
about this pace of negotiation?
Because I remember I saw in one
of your talks about basically
how exactly the dynamics
of the negotiation--
so this kind of explains--
NOELLE SELIN: So
yeah, nothing happens
until the very last minute,
which is interesting.
It's sort of like grad school.
But there's a lot
of spinning wheels
for we have to discuss things,
we have to be deliberate.
Again, 2002 was when there was
a global scientific assessment
that says we ought to
do something about it.
And then years and years.
Mandate for
negotiations was 2009.
So then you schedule a meeting.
Usually scheduled
meetings may be
for a negotiation like this
every six months or so,
five or six day meeting.
Everyone has to get there.
You've got
interpretation issues.
So the six UN languages
are simultaneously
interpreted in the main room
in main plenary discussions.
Most of the in the
card discussions
are in English because
everyone speaks English
except for a few.
And if you're one of the few
that doesn't speak English,
that's a problem.
We try to avoid
sending those people.
But some countries don't
have a great English speaking
capacity.
That's been mostly a
problem in my experience
with French-speaking
African countries,
have the most problem with
finding the person who speaks
English.
Lately it's been
a little better.
The older people often
didn't speak English.
Younger people are actually
sort of taken over now
in a lot of these countries.
And so the idea of the 65 year
old person that didn't quite
get the message that
English was-- wasn't taught
English in school is no longer
at the head of the delegation.
It's now the 40 year
old that basically
went to school in
an English speaking
country in a lot
of these countries.
So that's one issue.
Again, if your country's
language is not
one of the six UN
languages, you've
got to speak on that
language on the floor.
So if you're from
Brazil, you're probably
speaking English on the floor
because Portuguese is not
a UN language.
So again, if you're
from Japan, you're
probably speaking English on
the floor unless for some reason
you know French.
But you've got to
pick one of the six.
So English, French, Spanish,
Arabic, Chinese, and Russian.
So that's another
thing that makes
things go fairly
slowly, when you have
simultaneous interpretation.
And it means that it can kind
of be a glacial pace for awhile
while people say, hello,
I'm going to thank
the chair for negotiations.
And I want to
respectfully say that I
disagree with paragraph two.
But in a 10 minute speech.
And then the next
person says I also
disagree with paragraph two.
And you have to go through
everybody in the countries
before they actually
say, you all
go talk about paragraph
two in the room over there.
Once that happens and
you get to a deadline,
you can agree on paragraph
two relatively rapidly.
But you need that whole process
of getting to agreement there.
So again, writing the
text-- the secretariat
supports a lot of that.
But again, you're
drafting in a big group
of people with 160
countries going word
by word through a document
that has legal force.
It's a tough thing.
And that's why the science, I
think, doesn't really come in.
Because the complexity of
the negotiations, it's part
of the reason why I think
the chemicals program has set
up this process pretty
well, is that they say,
we're going to do the
scientific assessment.
We're all going to agree.
We're going to stamp it.
We're going to move on.
If you have a question
on the science,
we'll kick it back to
the scientific group,
we'll do an assessment,
we'll agree, we'll move on.
So it's kind of like the
science sets the basis
and then we're
going to negotiate,
which means it's not
always the optimal outcome.
But it gets done.
Something gets done.
Now I did some analysis
actually of what
would happen in mercury
in the environment
as a result of this treaty
with the best guesses of what
it would involve.
And pretty much the conclusion
was avoided increases.
So without the treaty,
our business as usual
would be mercury increasing
in the environment.
With the treaty,
probably pretty steady.
So again, if you want mercury
to decrease in the environment,
you've got to then go through
and look at your technology
regulations for
emissions and probably
ratchet those down through
the treaty process itself.
Otherwise, you're not
going to actually improve.
It's also more legally
and politically
important at this point then
environmentally important
because it sends a pretty
clear message that mercury
is a pretty bad thing
internationally,
and that has a really
big signaling mechanism.
If you're a company and you're
thinking about using mercury
in a process-- which might be
the easiest way to do things,
because mercury has some really
neat chemical properties--
this kind of thing will make
you think twice about it.
So that idea that there's sort
of a consensus around mercury
is bad, and they're increasing
amounts of regulation,
and countries are beginning to
figure out that mercury is now
going to regulate more has
a strong political force,
whereas the technical
regulations might not
be the operative part.
So again, legally and
politically important.
Not so much
environmentally yet-- but
might be in the future
as amendments come in,
as the technical
requirements-- there's
a lot to be decided on
exactly what technologies
might be considered in terms
of emissions regulations.
And that's an open
question right now.
And it's going to be decided
by the technical groups
and by conference of
parties negotiations.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So after ten
years of working on this,
do you eat fish?
NOELLE SELIN: I do eat fish.
There are fish that are
relatively low in mercury.
So the key in dietary
advice on mercury
is you don't want
people not eating fish.
Fish high in omega 3s, but low
in mercury-- unfortunately,
that's the herrings
of the world.
And I don't want herring.
But again, I also
figure there's lots
of things that are going to kill
me faster, like French fries.
So you've got to take
them one at a time.
PROFESSOR: Any more questions?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So we're not going to go
through today your deliverables.
Tony may have mentioned,
or Alexis last time,
that we divided your groups.
Did they tell you?
Yeah?
So we're going to be meeting
with you independently
over the next few
days to go over
where your project
is in preparation
for the final report.
And then next week we're going
to be talking about strategy.
So we're going to try to get
everything we have covered
and try to frame it in a
more concrete discussion.
So what are we going to do
with everything we've learned.
You're going to
eventually want to make--
drive a change in a company.
How should I start with
all these inventions,
the technical side, now the
political side, the NGO side,
the complexity of the networking
you have to deal with.
And we're going to
have a discussion
around that next time.
And we're going
to probably bring
some of the things you
have already worked
on your specific case studies.
And Wednesday we're going
to have the head of EMC
to decide to actually
tell us how they did it.
It's very interesting.
Today I was meeting this
morning with-- the last few days
I have met with P&G, Intel,
and Nike sustainability heads,
and how they have been
thinking through this process.
So it strikes me they're
as confused as probably you
are at the point.
Exactly what do I do about it?
At the end, you have to
make some specific actions.
So we're going to at least bring
some of the ideas to the table
over the next two sessions.
With that, I that I
will see you on Monday.
Thank you.